l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
momento sono fa vj e oggi siamo per la
prima volta sul mio canale con la
nintendo switch e non solo se notato
all'interno switch ma siamo sul gioco
della vita
stiamo per giocare a super mario o di 6
o d si odi o di sé ed è per questo
motivo che nell'ultima settimana mi sono
fatto crescere i baffi sopra il
somigliare a mario è il risultato
siamo la stessa cosa
oggi si mentre caricherà la partita
volevo ringraziare veramente di cuore
nintendo per avermi permesso di giocare
aodi perché io ci ho già giocato come
vedete ho già cliccato continua quindi
mazza che caricamento rapido e già
qualche giorno che ci gioco perché la
nintendo mi ha consentito di provarlo in
anteprima è per me questo è un onore
incredibile pirata ho già fatto un sacco
di cose ho preso un miliardo di lune le
lune sarebbero gli obiettivi di questo
gioco gli obiettivi principali bisogna
raccogliere delle lune per potenziare
quella che è la odyssey che la nave di
mario che ti permette di andare attorno
al mondo perché ci sono un sacco di
mondi da esplorare
adesso quale mancano anno l'ho già prese
e o il suo george ha finito lo già
finito io e voi non avete idea di quante
brescia ho passato ha indotti a
settimana sul suo gioco in un giocattolo
questo io non già collezionato 55 di
lune da quando ho iniziato a giocare
quindi non vi spoiler o troppo diciamo
il regno della city era quello che
aspettavo dall'inizio ho già sbloccato 5
anzi con questo sei mondi in questo
momento sono andato al regno delle
sabbie che tra l'altro mi sa che ho
completato quasi al cento per cento
perché ci sono stato veramente troppo di
grosso livello
la particolarità di se vi faccio un
attimo vedere come funziona la
particolarità di questo mario rispetto
agli altri e che va beh a parte i
miliardi di mondi da esplorare ma non è
tanto quello il fatto è che il cappello
che ho in testa è un personaggio a se si
chiama capi quando tu lo lanci così lui
attacca i nemici ti permette di prendere
il controllo dei nemici a questo punto
comunque direi di fare direttamente
quello nuovo regno della city visto che
negli altri ho già fatto quasi tutto
ovviamente non tutto al cento per cento
perché ci sono un sacco di roba da fare
è spuntato un materasso aiuto questo
impedimento e gli oggetti possono essere
cos'è sta roba che è successo ma non
battere bowser ma adesso subito così
aiuto ma veramente no ma scusatemi
imposizione si continui a rubarmi la
ragazza da 800 anni ci sarà un motivo
la storia in realtà è che bowser ha
rapito pitch non l'avreste mai detto lo
so perchè sarai anche grande e grosso ma
con i cappelli non ci sai fare il giro
non è charme neanche con l'alito secondo
me ma devo battere pausa così importate
bene ragazzi giocavano su per me ha
fatto bowser subito ma devo catturarli
il cappello cosa devo fare di preciso
aiuto sì cosa faccio credo che non ti
stia mario veramente ayane ha colpito mi
ha fatto malissimo
devo colpirlo così ok a iamm all'inizio
anni mi ha fatto male
la velista pagnottella in teoria per
battere i boss se questo è uguale agli
altri ma credo di sì perché sempre così
devi colpirli tre volte ogni volta che
lo colpisce aumenta la difficoltà fa più
cose ma tu perfetto perfetto
mancano ott la tua vita novità vita come
fatto trovare una vita eh vabbè quanti
capelli e nonostante questo no raga non
ci credono battuto subito davvero si
porti i dati sono sudati giuro sospinto
no sì c'era ovviamente non ho vinto la
battaglia finale però l'ho preso un
cazzotto fuoco e vabbè
è più o meno la stessa sensazione della
finanza più o meno regno dell'oblio qui
non sono finito in città sono finito nel
regno dell'oblio mise anche scassata la
navicella quanto vedo a posto mario
questo è capitata questa è la vera forma
di capi che il mio cappello
ci mancava solo che si scassa se la
odyssey devo trovare delle lune per
ripararla quante ne servono 10 lune va
bene dei ragazzi niente vero il mio
della city ma c'è un questo no vabbè ma
dai ma tutti ma poi quando devo
registrare succede non sai cosa mi
rubano il cappello e tuttora te non fare
non fanno scherzi maledizione il
cappello l'altro c'è una luna ingabbiata
lassù la vedo da qua a genio
puoi darmi il caffè no va beh non ci
voglio credere per favore blu
beh adesso la botta la presa e non ci
avevo pensato
prego prego 50 è ora comunque a ok a
posso prendere il controllo di questi se
tu prendi il controllo dei nemici puoi
comandare i nemici ai un'abilità
speciale in questo caso mi a lungo ai
weiwei perfetto le bene la prima in
teoria facendoli arrivare tar che siamo
a due
almeno 22 l'ho già preso un conto in
sospeso comunque è la fermi bravo
lorenzo niente che ora non ce la faccia
prende posso provarci tutto il giorno
non ci riesco ferma lì e non è che si
sta muovendo voglio tutto calcolato
o era di fino lo so non capisco era
difficile arpac come no non mi faresti
scherzi eh no non è vero non è bello sta
mentendo ci ho messo un'ora sono morto
sei volte per niente ma veramente a in
teoria qui sotto ce ne dovrebbe essere
un'altra
ok questo l'ho presa questa cielo fin
qua almeno quest finalmente un livello a
cui mi devo far vedere stati qatar haga
questa è una figata
ve la faccio vedere quando non muoio per
ora faccio vedere ve lo giuro in teoria
c'è un modo per la pelle sopreso stata
luna c'è un modo per entrare nel muro
che adesso non lo vedi allora questo
video eccolo perfetto ra qua e non
l'avevo visto in me sono in realtà
queste porte sono dei livelli bonus
seriamente diventa 2d e poi fare le cose
in 2d e fichissima sta cosa
ok
cinque ragazzi in questo 10 siamo a metà
ce la posso fare è più difficile di
quanto pensassi sto livello mangiato
salvare un'altra un altro anno così sono
frammenti di stelle si sa contare grazie
capi molto gentile ok noni oggi non
riesco a saltare i dimentico che
effettivamente devo prendere il
controllo dei nemici per andare avanti
se no
questi qua che sto prendendo sono
frammenti di di luna così ho trovato una
stanza segreta rega ma che figata
no vabbè che ho trovato non me
l'aspettavo mai perfetto la sfida un
attimo ciao posso rubarti tutto loro che
dietro si grazie
massimo quanto gentilissimo captain
blood ha trovato una luna fantastico ho
fatto una cosa senza neanche volerlo
benissimo altro quando tu prendi il
controllo di un nemico il nemico inizia
a somigliare a mario dopo l'ultima luna
scusate una sommersa forse qua dentro
giusto eccola perfetto le ho prese tutte
5 adesso mi spunta quella vera eccola lì
bene sette su dieci oraria siamo a me ne
mancano tre incredibile
e chi l'aveva vista quella perfetto
siamo 8 rachele mancando senti fa in
europa utile visto che minuti il
cappello è che non sai mai che fa vieni
qua spaccami questo molto gentile ma non
c'era niente una stella è una luna scusa
mi sono abituata a mario galaxy ok 9
guarda e l'ultima luna dove è poi uno
deve stare calmo no vedo di doverla fare
esplodere con questo ma non ho voglia di
farlo e quindi vado in cima
no grazie
ok ciao todd questo successo destro a e
crisi cup brevi spiega oraria crisi cup
è una specie di negozio che lo trovo in
giro in tutti i mondi di mario e se tu
entri cosa vuoi più che mi guardi così
sai non sono venuto qui in esplorazione
ma per aprire un negozio che te ne pare
fece vasta clientela vedo sei un genio
del marketing crisi capcom che vi faccio
vedere cos'è criticate tipo negozio che
ti vende delle personalizzazioni per il
tuo personaggio tipo il cappello che io
ho addosso non è quello normale standard
me lo sono comprato in un altro negozio
crisi cup perché quello normale questo
poi c'è quello di gigi doug ciò la
maschera e boccaglio e poi c'è questo è
troppo figo ma c'è anche questa che però
non metto per dignità
no questo questo lo voglio invece questo
sì questo senso grazie prendo anche il
cappello da avviato al resto elemento
subito a prescindere bellissimo bene
scherzavo cambio look sexy posso andare
via grazie cos'è tieni premuto b per
planare ok
vabbè non so guidare non so guidare
neanche alla macchina io come puoi
pretendere queste cose
ah ok ok grazie sia stato molto gentile
non raccolte quanto e lo raccolte 11 mi
sa vabbè comunque ne bastavano dieci
quindi perfetto
le riparazioni funzionali in cinque
minuti dai famigliari la oggi si è stata
riparata bene bene possiamo andare in
città e ci ho messo poco a ripararla
perché io io meccanico oltre che
idraulico ma no pensavo ci fosse il sole
come piove
[Musica]
cosa è successo epa per quanto disastro
ho come l'impressione che le cose non
stiano andando molto bene da queste
parti beh potremmo andare peggio
potrebbe piovere non sono simpatici
penso io tranquilli per la pioggia non
posso far niente quello dipende dal
mente o però qua ci penso io faccio
fuori io bowser devo farvi restarono
paraga se tu prendi il controllo di un
bomba che sarebbero questi per non
conoscesse supermario però è grave se
non lo conoscete puoi saltare sopra
altri goomba saltare sopra altri bomba
ancora e fare una torre gigante di bumba
puoi arrivare a quanto questi sono due
mameli magno che è un piacere
no mi se magnano a me stavo scherzando
no sono vivo sono che non so come ho
fatto a non chiedere ci sono i cantieri
non è solo un gioco per bambini e per
ragazzi mario è anche un gioco per
vecchi
vabbè gli ascensori sono troppo
mainstream di vento parte della corrente
per sapere cosa state esattamente
facendo ok mi sa che questo per batterlo
mi devo tirare su le maniche però non lo
so questo è il boss del del mondo
credo che sia un po difficile
niente non ci ha neanche provato in un
uso morto a prescindere
[Musica]
beh sono caduto almeno in piedi mi sa
che no veramente aiuto
devo veramente far fuori questo album
ok dai con la mira perfetto
a colpirlo più volte adesso che perfetto
grazie grazie capi gentilissima sto
facendo tutto io ma fa niente matoc e
schivate incredibile cioè potrei potrei
batterlo sul serio ragala abbattiamolo
in borsa al primo tentativo senza
neanche di provarci
cosa che non mi riesce spesso e prove no
mi ha colpito maledizione va bene
no che è perfetto vai vai colpisci
colpisci
perche non ci ha battuto bastavano due
volte
e se battete quei boss molto più forti
del normale
questo era più forte in teoria ti danno
le tre lune che sono più di una luna be
nice
[Musica]
quindi ragazzi direi che possiamo
concludere qua con questo finale con
tanto di orchestra perché sono riuscito
a battere due bossi in un video il primo
non me l'aspettavo neanche giorno ciao
ho azzeccato veramente gettato giorno
sul serio però questo non me lo spoiler
o perché sono rispondono troppa roba
pero che questo video vi sia piaciuto a
me mario sta facendo impazzire da giorni
sono contento avevano portato sul canale
in realtà il gioco esce domani che il 27
è giocato un po perché voleva essere un
po allenato prima di fare il gameplay ma
sono morto lo stesso miliardo di volte
ma sono riuscito a battere del boss e
quindi non è neanche troppo male
ricordatevi solo una cosa se andate da
crisi cup
vestitevi così perché credo che sia il
migliore poi magari trovo di meglio più
avanti però per adesso il migliore che
ho trovato sicuramente meglio il costume
da bagno
voi avete vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa
in sé mi piace sul momento e mi piace
anche vari social cominciato da una
descrizione sapersi schede e noi ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo video non
portarmi di volta il microfono lì perché
sennò il bella ragazzi non si sente da
ragazzi
[Musica]